the headline yesterday that shook up the
NBA came from Ric Bucher the bleacher
report columnist and longtime great NBA
insider why doesn't anyone want to play
with lebron anymore and Rick had a lot
of comments from Kevin Durant and Rick
joins us now Rick good morning how
surprised are you at the reaction to
this column I'm not really surprised
it's LeBron there's always a reaction he
is he has supported our industry more
than any human being on the planet right
now if you write about LeBron no matter
what it might be it is certainly going
to generate a response I believe that
what was different here is that I was
able to get a number of high profile
guys not just Kevin Durant certainly
Kevin Durant speaking at length about
LeBron and about the yin and yang of
playing with LeBron and the fact that
you had people on the record talking
about what it is that that goes into
playing with arguably still the best
player in the league is what generated
that response I'm curious the tone of
Durant's comments because sometimes you
can read it in it and it reads
differently but what was the tone of his
comments talking about the toxic
atmosphere around LeBron well I think
yeah I think that that has really been
missed resent misrepresented as it has
been truncated and and dispersed through
other outlets he made a point that it's
a toxic environment that is created by
what he described as the fanboys in the
media that and and he says I mean the
quote is there he says it's not LeBrons
fault at all that quote or that aspect
somehow didn't make it to the the final
version that everyone else is as
utilized or even the fact that he's
saying the media generates that and he's
saying it from the perspective of other
players walking into it that there is an
idolatry when it comes to LeBron that if
you're another superstar you another
player walking into
that and being surrounded by that on a
daily basis toxic is a little strong
nonetheless a a weird certainly a weird
environment and look it that's Katie's
perspectives he is certainly has a as a
right to it and I just look it's with
anything we can go back to the the he
tolls in Miami we can go back to the
Jordan Bulls days you know any great
group has an entourage and has a a buzz
around it that creates a certain
atmosphere and environment that if not
toxic can certainly be powerful and
strained and if you're not conditioned
for it then it can be looked at as a
negative based on these comments and
maybe based on the comments alone could
Kevin Durant you know what do you want
to be in this environment with LeBron
James yeah well that's where sort of the
nuance of the conversation because he
made a point of saying you know guys
like Kawhi and Paul George he could see
why they wouldn't want to be in this
atmosphere and he has been circumspect
about as I said in the story you know he
hasn't been he's been somewhat coy about
what his plans are for next year he's
not committing one way or the other
whether he's staying at Golden State or
or exploring his free agent options I
for all that he said I everything else
that I know about where he's at mentally
I don't think that he's headed to LA I
don't think that he's he's headed to
play with LeBron largely because if he
leaves Golden State it's because he
wants he hasn't gotten the credit for
what he's accomplished here because of
what they already had he wouldn't get
that credit Cohen to play with LeBron
next so he's looking for something other
than that but his description of that
atmosphere I don't believe is the thing
that would discourage him from joining
LeBron
wondering about the personalities and I
felt all along if Kauai left Toronto and
I don't even think he leaves Toronto but
if he ends up in LA and be with the
Clippers Paul George I understand why he
liked the atmosphere in Oklahoma City
there's certain guys who were just wired
for certain city like Tim Duncan in New
York while he would have been a great
player he would have hated it like San
Antonio was perfect for him there so
that's why when I if you go in with
LeBron man you got to be all in and it's
coming at you in directions that you
don't even see it coming and and it's
like how do we create a story today
other than LeBron had an unbelievable
game last night that's secondary it's I
don't know Miz he's spending - you
playing too many minutes what's Kobe
really saying about LeBron and we're
gonna win championship it's there
because everybody has got to get a story
and it's got to be different
it's got to be tiring on these players
well no doubt and it's also it's what's
the redeeming value for you to be in
that atmosphere and as you know any
number of guys said to me off the record
are just in conversation if if the team
wins if there's success it's well it's
LeBron and if the team is somehow has
some shortcomings it's well it's the
supporting cast and which means you like
anybody who's not LeBron is the problem
it's the coach
it's the GM it's the supporting cast
it's the it's the second star who's not
enough of a second star and and I think
the great distinction here is that we've
now seen all of this play out we've seen
Chris Bosh go and have to transform
himself we've seen Kevin Love have to
transform himself we've seen Kyrie
Irving get beat up for what he is or he
isn't and don't you know that you're
playing with LeBron James and it's a
it's a different demand and the reality
is you know the players that I talk to
will tell us a LeBron has nothing to do
with that I'm not so sure about that
but the bulk of it does come from
Media and the wet and the perception
that we create talking to Ric Bucher
Bleacher Report Writer columnist why
doesn't anyone want to play with lebron
anymore as the title of his latest
column okay with that being said give me
the player that you think would want to
go into this environment with LeBron
next season I don't know of a Caesar
that it's a matter of the players that
are available yeah you know and and part
of the the challenge here is also
they're all guys or were Paul George
Kawhi Leonard Kevin Durant these are all
ball handling forwards who can play
either position well that's essentially
what LeBron is so there's a duplication
there and not to say that duplication
doesn't work but again for where these
guys are is it isn't ideal no it's it's
not ideal so you know I believe that
ultimately the guy that the Lakers get
to fill that spot isn't necessarily
going to be a free agent I mean maybe
it's a Chris Middleton it's a what and
no offense to Chris or any of the guys
but you know sort of that second-tier
guy who would would step in and and sign
as a free agent but that if they're
going to get the big name and Anthony
Davis is the name that's out there the
most and certainly the clutch agency
that LeBron is part of is also
represents ad also resents represents
Kentavious caldwell-pope it's the DNA of
clutch and the Lakers has really it's
been synthesised now they're making a
deal for an ad and I'm not I'm not
reporting anything I'm not suggesting
something has been discussed but I see
them I see it more likely that they
trade away some of that young talent and
get an Anthony Davis then I see them
just outright signing a free agent what
would they have to give up now all
hypothetical but but what the Lakers
have to give up to get Anthony Davis
look it's gonna be I mean that is
obviously is how good is are the
pelicans and squeezing as much as they
can I would I would expect at this point
if you go through free agency or you
look at free agents and you go you know
what we're not going to get somebody and
LeBrons here and he's turned 34 this
year and he's about to turn 35 next
season like we need to make this happen
now the leverage certainly would be from
the Pelican side of things their ability
to say we want picks we want you know
Ingram we want lawns of all we want you
know we want at least two of your young
stars and we want at least two draft
picks going forward because we're taking
a seminal talent we're taking a
franchise cornerstone and we're moving
him your way and it becomes a
cat-and-mouse game because at this point
ad still has enough left on his contract
that it's not the pelicans are forced to
make a chain move but at the same time
mmm if it's made clear to them that he's
not staying you want to get as much as
you can to keep the ball moving and this
is what I wanted to know with the Lakers
is can you keep this team intact just to
find out what you have this year or are
they going to run the risk of we're not
as good as people expect us to be or you
make one of those moves where you like I
just want to see what if Ingram
continues to get better or Kuzma Lonzo
you know you can you can deal him but I
just want to know if you feel like hey
do we really need a big name or can we
get to contributing gun like I don't
know it's just a feeling out process
Rick that I I think it's really it's
it's sensitive for the Lakers because
magic is so competitive you want to win
you want to have a good product you've
waited for this moment and it feels like
you're gonna have to wait till next year
to really roll out the product that you
want well and I believe that's true and
I believe they knew that going into this
year that this was going to be a year of
discovery and this is where it does get
tricky timewise because of where LeBron
is in his trajectory so it is and but
this was tricky from the very beginning
and the you know the bottom line
is that are you gonna say no to LeBron
no your your the Lakers you're not
saying no to LeBron but you also have to
go into it with eyes wide open as far as
where he is in his career and what you
have on your roster and that the the the
real giveaway in terms of that they were
willing to utilize this year as a point
of discovery for their young talent is
that they signed all the all the veteran
talent they got are all on one-year
deals they were preserving the the space
for next year and I do believe that you
know they'll figure out who fits and who
doesn't a lot of this too is and this
goes back kind of to the story which is
you know everything always naturally
gravitates to LeBron being at the center
of things
can he shift and make room for other
guys to contribute and can you make that
work because generally the way teams
that he has competed with that have
challenged four championships
they have been specific they've been
built with role players great role
players but role players and most people
would look at and go guys it's too bad
that LeBron can't get that great
superstar next to him the superstars
that came in were diminished into role
players when they came in
Chris Bosh Kevin Love I I'm old enough
to remember what they were before they
got there and you know it was unique
with with Dwayne because it's Wayne way
because of the relationship that they
had to but even Dwyane Wade had to go
from the leader of that team to LeBron
it's really time for you to take over
and so ultimately that worked but it
worked largely because of the
relationship that was already
established I'll leave you with this the
team that goes further in Los Angeles
this year's the Clippers and Lakers
I love what the Clippers have become but
as you and I both know the postseason is
different than the regular season I
could see where the Clippers actually
have a better regular-season record than
the Lakers but the Lakers because of
LeBron largely because of LeBron but
rajon rondo
they have some veterans who have been
through the battles they scare me more
than what the Clippers have because it
comes down to who's your star who leads
you in that postseason who can get a
bucket when all else has failed Clippers
are a nice story and they're a nice team
they don't have that proven track record
in the postseason good visit with you
Rick thanks for joining us we appreciate
the time
oh it's BP thank you buddy why doesn't
anyone want to play with LeBron anymore
that's so Ric Bucher bleacher report for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]